Daniel H pink what is your book free
agent nation about a book is about the
rise of independent workers freelancers
eel answer self-employed professionals
proprietors of very small businesses and
the book tells the story of how this new
worker arose what this new workers role
is in the economy and in our lives and
how it's really affecting the way we
work and way we live you open up the
book by telling us that you vomited on
the vice president the United States I
wasn't actually on him it was in his
office was close it was close i was
before i chose the more honorable work
of journalism i worked in politics for
many years and most recently as a
speechwriter for chief speechwriter for
Vice President Al Gore and one day after
working way too hard I left a meeting in
his west wing office fainted and began
throwing up into a bowl that was a gift
i think from the Queen of Denmark and
that was sort of a signal that it was
time for me to go and choose a different
way to navigate my work in my life what
years did you work for vice president I
worked for him 95 96 and 97 why why did
I work for him oh I think Al Gore is a
terrific a leader I think he's a very
principled man and he was uh actually a
pretty good boss he's for especially for
a writer he's someone who's written a
book before he's someone who was a
journalist so he has respect for the
written word and he's smart and
challenging and really a good person to
work for actually didn't want to know so
much about why him as much as why be a
speech rock what got you into that he
also wrote for Robert rice yes uh what
got me to speech writing was really my
lack of aptitude for almost anything
else I had worked in politics for a long
time on a series of losing campaigns and
eventually migrated into the policy and
communications side of campaigns and
more and more found myself writing
speeches because I was if nothing else I
was a fast typist and ended up falling
to that world and liking a quite a bit I
really I really enjoyed it it's a
interesting juncture of the
communication side of politics in the
policy side of politics what is your
hometown my hometown is central ohio
columbus ohio so where did you get the
idea for free agent nation when did that
all come together those three words well
what
happened was that I actually ended up
becoming a free agent myself after I
left Al Gore's office I decided that I
would go out of my own and try to work
for myself because after a decade or so
of holding a job I said you know this
job thing gets a little bit old after a
while maybe I can be make the same
amount of money but have a slightly
better life if I work for myself so I
moved from the White House to the third
floor of our house in washington DC the
pink house and ended up writing speeches
and articles for a series of clients now
I was fortunate in that my wife had a
job and therefore health insurance so it
wasn't necessarily a plunge into free
agency but kind of a gentle gentle jump
and so what happened as they started
doing this as I looked around and I said
man there are a lot of people who seem
to be doing this and yet I realize their
understanding of this world was
remarkably remarkably small I wrote a
magazine story for a magazine called
Fast Company which got an incredible
response from readers just hundreds of
emails instantly and but what I said is
if all these people who are working for
themselves we don't really know that
much about them and so I said well how
does any nation endeavor to understand
itself well it goes out and takes a
census so that's what I decided to do
for over a year my wife and I and our
young daughter and then another daughter
traveled around the United States and I
interviewed hundreds and hundreds of
independent workers about their lives
and dreams and their troubles to try to
get a census of what this new world of
work is about when did you do that
traveling I did it in the fall of 98 all
through 99 in a little bit of early 2000
how'd you pay for them the they find
people at Warner publishing who gave me
a nice book advance and allowed me to
conduct this research this your first
book yes why would they hire you to do a
book and give you the kind of money
needed to travel all the United States
how did you convince them that this was
a book well I mean I explained to them
how large this population of people was
how there really is not a comprehensive
coverage of this phenomenon and to my
mind and I thira viewers have said this
is really one of the most important if
not the most significant phenomenon in
the world of work today especially after
the.com collapse there was all this hype
about calmness and dotcom that but I
really think the most fun
mental economic change is in the form of
how people work and there hasn't been a
comprehensive account of what it looks
like how it happened and where it's
going how old are you 37 where did you
meet your wife I met my wife in law
school one of the probably the only
valuable thing I got out of law school
and what's her name her name is Jessica
learner in would you go to law school a
yale law school so I met my wife at yale
law school and she a lawyer she was she
now she now is a free agent it takes he
also takes care of our kids but I met my
wife at law school which was as I said
but the only valuable thing I got out of
law school now he's had you move around
the United States what we would do is we
would usually fly to a particular region
and then from that region kind of
decamped there for a few weeks and then
drive out so we would go to Northern
California fly say to San Francisco fan
out from San Francisco for a few weeks
some of the some portion of it I did by
myself Los Angeles I did by myself
Seattle I did by myself how old was your
daughter your first daughter when she
was she started the roadshow when we
when she was to hell what's her name
Sophie you now have another one Eliza
and she was on this trip she can't well
she came in into the picture in 1999 so
she missed some of the early stages of
the trip and ended up taking some of the
later stages in 99 and early 2000 how
many people did you talk to oh boy
face-to-face interviews was well over
300 I also did a number of phone
interviews I have a website free agent
nation com where I did a online census
also a free agent so I had about 12 over
1,100 people who filled out a kind of a
mock census about what how they operated
their lives name one person that you
talked to that you thought was
interesting and tell us why Betty Fox
Betty Fox grandma Betty grandma Betty I
also known as grandma Betty calm grandma
Betty is a now 70 year old woman when I
met her she was 68 years old and at the
age of 67 she found herself in a really
serious predicament Betty Fox was
widowed at a very young age
early 30s and this is at the time that
Betty Ford an another Betty from New
York was urging women to seize the
workforce but Betty Fox found herself
getting seized by the workforce she was
widowed she had two sons to raise and so
she took a series of jobs the jobs were
not high level high paying jobs and she
would end up losing a job here and there
not because of her performance but
because a company would go under and so
finally at age 67 this woman 67 year old
woman in Bayside Queens her company
moves too far away for her to commute
and so here she is out of work no
pension and a long time to live on this
earth and so what she did is she her son
Marty had was a bank technology officer
he hooked her up with something called
web TV which allows people to surf the
internet using their television set and
before long Betty started looking around
and she said well there's some really
interesting material out here
particularly for older Americans like me
but it's a mess it's poorly organized
it's hard to find things so she started
organizing it herself her son got her a
domain that is grandma Betty calm she
started organizing her sights and before
long people started coming she started
getting emails about where to make how
to make peanut brittle where to get
ourselves certain health problems where
to buy certain kinds of clothing and she
would dutifully in her Queens living
room answer all these emails and before
long almost unbeknownst to herself she
had created what the internet gurus call
a portal and before long she started
getting advertising and affiliate
relationships and so here's this woman
who went from having no job and having a
somewhat bleak set of circumstances to
using the internet and using her own
gumption to establish a presence on the
web and at the end of the book I talk
about grandma betty was eventually
acquired she had of these venture-backed
internet companies come to her apartment
in Bayside Queens and sit across from
her just as you and I are sitting right
now and say grandma Betty we want to buy
you out and she drove a very hard
bargain and remained she ended up taking
a nice deal with a company called I
grandparents but remained a free agent
still alive still working out of her
living room in Bayside Queens so many of
these dot-coms have failed is this group
make it the free agents yeah
sure because the free agents were not
free agents had had less exposure free
Betty Fox's making it is making a great
these free the the dot-coms had failed
ended up burning through as everybody
knows tens of millions of dollars of
venture capital free agents if you work
for yourself you can't you have to make
a profit almost from day one and if you
don't make a proper from day one you're
in big trouble name another person and
tell us the story another person who I I
really enjoyed was um a woman named
Deborah Ricci who is in Northern
California she worked at a number of
high-tech firms Apple Computer probably
the most prominent and eventually tired
of it and what's interesting one of the
things that that had her make the break
and I heard this repeatedly in a lot of
interviews and and it really surprised
me the the frequency that it was
mentioned was she ended up leaving
because of ethical disagreements with
the company that really surprised me a
lot of these interviews people said well
you know the reason I left was I didn't
really I was asked to do something I
didn't think was quite right and so
there's a sense that people want a
greater freedom of conscience and their
work than they are able to get but
anyway Deborah see left her job and
ended up working as a marketing
consultant for herself she subsequently
adopted two children from Cambodia so
she's a single mom free agent and she
has one interesting element one
interesting part of her story where she
decided to buy a house and the bank said
to her we're not going to give you a
mortgage you don't have a job and she
said wait a second I'm here in Silicon
Valley where companies come and go you
know like the Sun and you're gonna tell
you're telling me that you're not going
to give me a loan because I don't have a
job listen I've got six clients and so
she shows her clients I've got six
Klein's if one of these clients goes
away I'm gonna still make my payments
but if i'm working at webvan say and web
then disappears you're not going to get
your payments and so she tried to
convince these this bank loan officer
that she was actually a safer risk
working for herself then she would have
been holding a job and I think that that
right there says a lot about how work
and risk have changed in America how
would you contact somebody in your
survey as an interesting question it's a
it's a very
a aggressive reporting job i would use
contacts and context of contact so i
don't know how I could have reported
this book without email so what I would
do is I would send out an email to
contacts in a particular region saying
I'm going to do this reporting anybody
who I should talk to I get a few more
emails back I would ask them questions
as well I'm looking for I was looking
for a wide variety of experience and
backgrounds people who had just started
people who had always been doing it but
they had to be free agents yes yeah so
you only interviewed free age yes
absolutely because I was taking a census
of free agent nation I didn't interview
well I interviewed a couple of people
who were contemplating going to free
agency but I wanted to get a picture for
the universe of people who were working
for themselves tell me everything that a
free agent has to be what are they in
terms of their attribute mate what would
make me a free agent what would you have
to be well you would have to be working
for yourself you would have to be
largely untethered from a large
organization and not dependent on an
institution or an employer so again one
of the interesting things here is the
term free agent is an imperfect term and
in some sense it's modeled after the
term the organization man which came out
in William White's book in the 1950s and
what he said is when he described the
organization man in his book he said I
use this term I can think of no other
better way to describe the people I'm
talking about and that's what I feel
with free agents I can think of no other
term to describe the people I'm talking
about so there isn't say a pure
scientific definition of who's a free
agent and who's not but people and even
people in the traditional world of work
often think of themselves as free agents
but what I focused on in my interviews
and in my census was people who worked
for themselves who was William white
William white was a fabulous journalist
at mostly at fortune magazine in the
1940s 50s and 60s who ended up using
journalism as a form of just incredibly
insightful sociology and so he he wrote
the book the organization man he also
did some really fascinating studies
where he would he studied how where
corporations located and made the
incredible finding that the main
decision about where a company's
headquarters was was proximity to the
sea
home he also spent some time literally
standing on the streets of New York
watching how people interacted so he was
kind of an anthropologist sociologist
journalist just a remarkable he died
about two years ago a remarkable figure
in American journalist you meeting no I
didn't I didn't he passed away as I said
about about two years ago how successful
was the book the organization man the
book did very well the book was kind of
a surprise bestseller because it was a
little bit on the academic side even
though it was written by a journalist
it's really endured over the years I'm
you and I can have a conversation about
the organization man and we can you can
say the phrase and people can ought to
know what you're talking about because
that term has become such a part of our
vocabulary you say in your book that
managers are toast I agree with that and
I'm god I do because I wrote it the wire
managers toast well I tend to think of
most managers at most companies sort of
subscribe to the vice principal School
of Management that is they act almost as
vice principals of the workplace their
job is to get people in trouble to watch
what people are doing to give people
detentions to give people hall passes
and I think that that way of working
that way of managing is fundamentally
flawed and outdated most workers are
self-motivated most workers talented
workers especially need organizations
much less than organizations need
talented workers so I think the manager
the future is a very different kind of
figure someone who is in a serious
student judge of talent someone who is
able to marshal a talent for the
particular task someone who operates
sort of my model for this is a
combination of Phil Jackson the great LA
lakers basketball coach a penny marshall
who was an actress and a writer and a
director in Hollywood and Steve Rubell
the guy who founded studio 54 who became
a great party Giver so someone who can
attract talent assemble them for a
particular task really understand the
idiosyncrasies of individual talent and
get the most out of them will you be a
free agent in 20 years I think so I
think so we can have a we can do this
show again in 20 years and we can find
out but I I think so it's hard now again
there's certain you know there's a you
write a book like free agent nation use
the term
ology of free agency and describe this
world as a nation and people declaring
their independence and it's somewhat
somewhat misleading because it's not as
if you become a free agent that is if
you leave corporate America to go to
free agent nation it's the same as
leaving Cuba and swimming to Florida and
you have to turn around and denounce
Castro it's less start than that I think
more and more people in the workforce
and this might even be the most profound
change are essentially going to hold
dual passports one in free agent a shin
one in corporate America and migrate
back and forth between the two now in
the days of the organization man that
was impossible if you left an
organization and said to your boss you
know what I think I'm gonna try to make
it on my own for a few years and then
came back five years later and said I'm
ready to come back there's no way they
would have taken you but today corporate
employers are recognizing that a stint
essa and self-employment makes a worker
extremely valuable Columbus Ohio your
hometown yes you met your wife at Yale
where were you before Yale I was us I
graduated from Northwestern University
in what subject in linguistics of course
linguistic yes why were you studying it
a linguist it's a fascinating topic and
in a way it's languages at the juncture
of both the science and the humanities
so I ended up taking both a lot of
courses in poetry but also courses in on
the psychology you know the circuitry of
the brain so it so it's to me at
linguistics was a quintessential liberal
arts discipline what were your parents
doing are they still active they still
yes what is my father's a free agent he
was actually an organization man for
many years he's a chemist he worked for
from her quarter of a century for a
large research organization connected to
Ohio State University my mother was a
schoolteacher now she works doing social
service programs for older people what
year did you graduate from Northwestern
86 and from Yale Law School 91 so what
happened then well the I graduated from
college I ended up working here in
Washington for one of ralph nader's
groups a pretty interesting group that
organized buyers of heating oil to
exercise greater leverage in the
marketplace
I actually started law school and left
because they didn't like it and ended up
going to India for a while to and do in
India I worked I traveled around I also
worked for a legal aid organization you
can live in the mid-1980s you could live
pretty cheaply in India you're a single
man in his early 20s how did you get
involved as Ralph Nader of through
contacts of contacts I didn't work
directly with Nader I work for one of
his constellation of groups doing what I
did media and outreach trying to get
people to join this cluster of consumers
who exercise their power in the
marketplace first politician you work
for first politician I worked for was a
guy named sherrod Brown who is now
congressman from Ohio he was used to be
Ohio Secretary of State he actually was
elected Ohio Secretary of State when he
was probably eight years younger than I
am right now and worked writing speeches
for him and then other campaigns you
worked on what two most prominent
figures would be a president bob kerrey
and Senator Geraldine Ferraro I worked
on bob carries presidential campaign in
1992 also worked on Geraldine Ferraro
Senate race there's a two most prominent
people of politicians for whom I've
worked in the middle of your book you
find yourself in terre haute indiana
right and you find yourself in the
Eugene V Deb's home and that the Larry
Bird motel mm-hmm but out of that I mean
what I'm getting at is here is this
whole business of where you are
politically and the union part of this
you've you've discovered something there
yeah what was it yeah well what I
discovered it I think the traditional
labor unions particularly industrial
labor unions have become passé they've
become ineffective I don't think they're
necessarily that great for workers but i
don't think that unions are dead in fact
i think free agents free agency could
trigger a rather robust union movement
but the unions i'm talking about are
more of the crafts unions the building
trades unions the entertainment industry
unions what i think is going to happen
is that smart unions are going to
recognize that hey you know what we're
becoming more and more a free agent
economy the idea that you can negotiate
ten-year collective bargaining
agreements five-year collective
bargaining agreements with large
employers it just doesn't work
what unions need to do and what many
workers in this economy are crying out
for our a place to learn new skills a
place to get health insurance and other
types of benefits a place to meet other
people in your profession and so that's
what the building trades unions do
that's what the entertainment unions due
to a large extent that's what the the
sports unions do and so what I sort of
had this moment in in terre haute
indiana of all places having visited the
jean vie debs home this great labor
leader who ran for president and also
staying at the Larry Bird motel Larry
Bird is from Larry Bird went to college
in Terre Haute Indiana the in
professional basketball labor
negotiations are something called a
Larry Bird exception where cut where
teams in in in in the NBA there's a
salary cap teams can only pay a certain
amount of money for all their players if
they want a higher free agent they can't
bust that salary cap but they can keep
one of their own players and bust the
salary cap that's known as the Larry
Bird exception and what i realize is
that more and more work is actually
becoming this kind of afl-cio NBA type
arrangement so that I think the unions
of the future the worker groups of the
future are going to be very much like
the sports unions that is they're going
to have a union that sets a minimum
maybe a salary minimum basic working
conditions and then beyond that people
are going to be represented by agents
more and more something like five
percent of workers who won more than
seventy five thousand dollars a year are
represented by talent agents what did
you learn at the Eugene V Deb's home oh
I learned that you know the idea that
this notion that the economy is changing
and someone needs to represent workers
is not a is obviously an enduring
American tradition and it's expresses
its expresses itself in fundamentally
different ways did you pay much
attention to him by the way in history
before you got there not significantly
you know there's not much to do in Terre
Haute so you know the only really two
big sites to see and it just sort of
inadvertently made this connection he
ran for president what's five or six
times yeah a few times he was in prison
for a while released by warren g harding
i believe i think so yeah pardon and all
that but but i was involved in it the
railroads could is there could that
duplicate itself the kind of world we
had back when he was
involved in the labor movement I don't
think so i think that that but but again
that sort of labor activism arose
because of the circumstances of the
underlying economy and i think that that
a new sort of labor movement could
emerge based on the circumstances of
this economy so what workers really need
to do no workers expect lifetime
employment at a single company but what
I think workers do demand and what they
want our valuable places to work
interesting places to work benefits it's
a big issue health care benefits
retirement benefits and a way to learn
new skills because today you learn some
skills for a job it's only you can do it
for 30 years you have to constantly
constantly sharpen your skills and
workers are looking for a venue to do
that ok go back here in 98 and part of
99 you're travelling around what's
what's your wife thinking about all this
she like this traveling around and I
think so I think she likes to help you
in any way oh she helped me by taking
our daughter to the zoo so I could do my
my interviews and I and my wife was just
an incredible sounding board for a lot
of these ideas my wife is a much more
rigorous thinker than I am you know in
law school I was in the portion of the
class that made the top ninety percent
possible and she was someone who was
getting straight A's through college
straight A's through law school and has
a very keen left brain sense of what's a
strong argument and what's not and so I
could not make an argument I cannot run
an argument passed her and without it
getting significantly sharpened in the
course of our conversation has it dawned
on you that Bill Clinton's 55 years old
and he and his wife went to Yale on met
at Yale and there you are 37 you met
your wife at Yale uh yeah I think it's
dawned on me I mean his book deal was
much more lucrative than mine did but
but what was the circumstances yet when
you met her I was in the class ahead of
her and that's about the same situation
you know i'm not sure i never really i
never really looked at the Clintons as a
model for my romantic life the reason I
mentioned this yeah because you're
obviously interested in politics but you
didn't talk about Bill Clinton as being
yeah just in time politician of this age
what does that mean wellston time policy
just in time in order to understand it
we have to take a step backward American
manufacturing
rehabilitated itself in the early 1990s
through a practice called just-in-time
manufacturing it used to be that
companies would make a whole bunch of a
product stick it in a warehouse and have
these huge inventory of products and
wait for customers to order them and we
would go into recessions when you had a
big industry a big inventory overhang
now in part that's what's happening
right now in the economy we have excess
inventory so just-in-time manufacturing
has not been the perfect panacea for
American manufacturing but a company
like Dell computer is a good example
Dale's inventory let is only about a day
so someone takes an order from dell dell
goes out and gets the parts assembles
the particular computer that the
consumer wants ships it to them I think
that our politics are moving in that
direction have moved in that direction
we used the task of political leaders
used to be to maintain a coalition
Democrats had racial minorities
environmentalists and labor unions
Republicans had big business social
conservatives and the goal of the
leaders of these parties was to keep
this big coalition intact to make sure
nobody fell off the wagon and in a sense
it's basically making sure you have a
giant inventory of voters and
constituents but I but because of
disenchantment with politics because of
the rise of independent voters because
of some changes in the economy it's no
longer possible for most parties to
maintain these giant inventories of
supporters so spective leader smart
leaders practice what I call just in
time politics they assemble the right
coalition for the right task and we see
that in it and I think Bill Clinton was
a master at this bill clinton I think
understood this he didn't call it that
of course I think he understood that and
I think he was masterfully skilled at
doing that so you take something like
the 93 budget agreement pass with one
vote in the house one vote in the Senate
we had this and it was a strange
coalition of people who voted for that
although that one was mostly Democrats
but but it was a it was a particular
coalition then he passes NAFTA well who
organized labor leaves him
environmentalists leave him but he does
a coalition of free-market thinkers of
Republicans and fashions another
coalition wins by one vote and the
coverage of it
kind of perils of pauline quality can
bill clinton do it is he going to get
the votes canny summon the will of all
these people and passed this thing and
there was a lot of commentary was all
he's not an effective leader look he has
these perils of pauline travails in
order to pass legislation but to my mind
that was very much like in these days of
waning party loyalty of an even split in
the parties of very strong special
interest groups that would have been
like some securities analyst saying
candela fixed bronc get Brian lamb his
computer it only has one day of parts
can it get the CPU can to get this great
oh my gosh it shipped the product and so
I think our politics now especially
right now where the Senate and the house
are basically split where the last
election was essentially a tie that our
politics are really just in time
politics and Bill Clinton is a true
master of that does Al Gore practice
just-in-time politics I might think of
Al Gore were elected president he would
have had to I think any smart leader has
to do that in order to get their their
legislation to get anything through I
mean we have essentially dead split in
this country politically and so and I
also think that a lot of the alignment
of voters and of special interest in of
interest groups is it is no longer
permit I mean Virginia pozdrow in her
book the future and its enemies talks
about Dinah mists and stasis as a
dividing line in how political thinkers
and political groups are operating but
that I'm glad you brought up Virginia
press trouble because she endorses your
book right she's Reason magazine she's
libertarian but you also have Tom Peters
it gives you a strong the best book on
work life since william h white would
that cost you cost me of sending him a
manuscript steve cases free agent nation
is the shape of things to come in the
internet century what debt question yeah
you know what these blurbs are these
blurbs are free did you do you know
these folks all I know Virginia press
troll I met Virginia purser on the
course of doing my reporting and
actually written a couple of speeches
for Steve Case Tom Peters I met maybe
once in my life naomi wolf yeah the
woman that the alpha beta 1
that advised al gore's she says a
groundbreaking book a readable and
persuasive benchmark and that's partly
because women are playing such a
prominent role in the free-agent economy
how so well first of all women are
becoming self-employed at 12 times the
rate of men women there are a lot of
women out there in the workforce who are
hitting a glass ceiling and not being
able to make it to the upper ranks of
corporations and they figured there'd be
better off on their own but they're also
a lot of women who don't even hit the
glass ceiling who look up there and say
man I don't want to be there anyway so
they're finding that the best way to
navigate their work lives is to go out
on their own and women for a whole set
of reasons tend to be extremely
effective free agents you consider
yourself a Democrat I'm a registered
Democrat in the dish I'm live in the
district of columbia I'm a registered
Democrat the reason i ask because you
know Virginia press travel and Naomi
with all these different names and jobs
where is this heading in politics though
because your survey yeah your online
survey I'll tilted more the people that
answered a more democratic than
Republican you say yeah in the survey
right is this a Republican Democratic
splitter of free agents Democrats I
don't think that either party really
understands this I mean I think that
Democrats tend to look at free agents as
people who are being cast out into this
eat this this perilous world of work by
evil corporations and Republicans tend
to think of self-employed people as
modern-day babbitt's who don't believe
in any role in government who don't
believe in any kind of form of social
justice and I think both are
fundamentally fundamentally misguided
I'll give you an example you know today
in America fewer than one out of ten
workers belongs in the private sector
belongs to a labor union fewer than one
of the ten workers works for a fortune
500 company yet our politics national
politics especially our this pitch
battle between big business and big
labor when most Americans have a rather
scant connection to eat a group I almost
took you up on your offer in this book I
think you may know what I'm talking
about because I read a book a week
you're going to make it easy for people
like me I didn't but and that is that
you you have a technique in here and
I've basically earmarked all of them
where you got one page on each chapter
that can kind of tell you everything
yeah why'd you do that I respect
people's time
when I'm asking people as an author is
to make a very significant commitment to
me they don't know me they have to be
hurt here about the book and they have
to make a significant commitment they
have to pay seventeen eighteen dollars
for the book and they have to spend
perhaps six or seven hours reading it
that's a significant commitment for
people to make so I want to make it as
easy for them as possible so what I did
it done at the end of every chapter was
fashioned something that I call the box
the box has four elements to it one
element is what i call the crux which
explains the point of the chapter in
about 150 words or fewer there's also
entry called the factoids which is one
startling factoid from the chapter there
is a section called the quote which
offers one representative quote from the
chapter and there's a an entry called
the word in every chapter because the
work is changing so fast and our
vocabulary is racing to catch up with it
there are many new words some of which
I've coined myself tried to coin myself
that this new world of work has spawned
so I'd like to offer a little vocabulary
word in every chapter so the point is
someone who wants to read this book
might not want to read every single
chapter they can look at the box get the
gist of it and and move on other people
who want to come back to it a lot of
readers who email me have told me that
they they like the box so they can if
they forget something they can come back
to it and be reminded of it and people
get to you on email now they're watching
the show oh absolutely yeah you know on
the book jacket I invite readers to
email me my email address is Dan at free
agent nation com I answer every email
from every reader again if you're a
writer people are making I'm so grateful
anytime anybody reads anything that i
right anytime anybody picks up anything
that I write because they are investing
their time and their brain power in
hearing what I have to say and I'm
firmly committed to hearing what they
have to say to and responding to them
dan at free agent nation com I'm going
to go through and pick out some factoids
and see what you say about them here's
the factor in the first chapter the
largest private employer in the United
States is not Detroit's General Motors
or Ford or even Seattle's Microsoft or
amazon.com but Milwaukee men power
Milwaukee's manpower incorporated a temp
agency mm-hmm how big is it I has 1100
offices it employs more workers than any
other corporation in America too
that's a remarkable remarkable change
why why is it a remarkable change why do
they do it yeah why is it a remarkable
what goes it used to be that someone
could go to General Motors and work
there for 30 years General Motors would
have this incredible roster of fixed
talent and employees and would just be
this behemoth and now essentially what
people are many people are doing is
working for manpower that is they get a
w-2 the paycheck and tax form from
manpower and are the employer of
manpower but actually do assignments at
other places 11,000 offices 1,100 I'm
sorry 1,100 offices and that's the
largest employer in the United States
yes how many I think it's upwards of 1
million factoid from chapter 2 two out
of three workers in California did not
hold traditional jobs the permanent
year-round full-time outside the home
employment arrangement that is the basis
of nearly all american labor laws and
social assumptions why only in
California well because that's where the
study came out of the study was from the
University of San Francisco and it
looked at how many people in California
have the kind of job where you leave the
house in the morning go to work
somewhere else work for someone else do
it full-time year-round essentially the
kind of job on which our social
assumptions are based our health
insurance system is based and in
California only one of the three workers
works that way which is a remarkable
when you think about how our tax system
is is girded to this way of working our
health insurance system is working to
this is Gordon to this way of working
even our transportation systems are
based on the idea that this is the norm
of how people work and California has
been on the edge of basically every
trend in the last 40 years so if two or
three workers in California have
so-called non-traditional jobs to me
that's a warning sign for the rest of
the country factoid in the third chapter
eighty-five percent of Americans today
we're not alive during the Great
Depression which means most of the
country lacks any conscious recollection
of widespread economic privation yeah
the significance of that I think is
quite interesting the the default
assumption of work in this country I
think has changed it used to be the
default assumption saying my grandpa
father's day was the fear of privation
because the Great Depression was
widespread economic privation privation
that reached deep into the middle class
but now seven out of eight people in
this country weren't alive during the
Great Depression they have no conscious
recollection of widespread economic
privation i underscore that word
privation because recessions even though
the painful are not privation or long
gas lines are not privation and so I
think that more and more people today
because of the incredible prosperity in
this country a country where two out of
three people own the homes they live in
is making people seek from their work
not only money but meaning factoid in
chapter 4 a 1999 Lou Harris survey of
1,000 self-employed Americans and small
entrepreneurs found that money was not
their top motivator nine out of 10
respondents said that quote setting
their own priorities and independence
influence their decision most to go out
on their own is that your situation oh
sure and actually that to me that was
one of the biggest surprises in doing
this interviews in doing these
interviews around the country and that
that survey simply confirms a lot of
what I found I thought when I started
writing when I started researching this
and interviewing people that this was a
big kind of hardheaded economic story
that people were being cast to the
periphery by the inexorable forces of
Information Age capitalism and that
wasn't really what I found people were
making very private decisions based on
much touchy touchy feely er values of
authenticity of freedom and almost
nobody mentioned money not that free
agents don't want to make money but
working this way is hard enough that
people don't people don't necessarily do
it to get rich who was the most and I
got to be right what monetary is who's
the most unusual person you interviewed
or unusual situation one of them was a
was a guy who is been named Bob milbourn
who's in San Francisco who came of age
in the days of the organization man and
was so miserable in his company and was
so fearful in his company which was
going through downsizings that dumb he
has to be fired he went into his boss
and said please just please fire me what
he went to severance uh he just wanted
he wanted to know he actually
wanted to relief from the anxiety of
being scared of being being fired he
wanted to he wanted simply the
punctuation mark at the end of this part
of his career what do you do that he
wended up going out on his own as a free
agent not as strong a little bit but
recognize that this world of work
working at a big bank was not for him
but he lacked somehow the gumption to
leap and so he asked to be pushed how
many states did you go to do i think it
was 24 so about half what does there any
part of the country didn't go too well I
didn't go to Alaska and Hawaii I didn't
go to some of the big states in the in
the great plains of Montana Idaho
Wyoming in the Dakotas but most of the
East Coast most of the West Coast a big
portion of the Southwest a big portion
of the Midwest did you get a sense that
some parts of the country are happier
than others I don't know about happier I
think that in the center of the country
this form of work is slightly slightly
more exotic than on the coast Seattle in
LA and San Francisco you know you go
into any starbucks coffee shop and there
are a zillion people sitting around
punching on their laptops same is true
in New York and even here in Washington
DC in the Midwest I think that there are
pockets where the free-agent workforce
is more robust Minneapolis is a good
example Chicago is a good example but in
some of the other in some other places
it's slightly more exotic factoid in
Chapter five more than half of american
households now on stocks up from only
one in five households in 1983 in two
thousand shareholders outnumbered voters
more citizens own stock than cast a
ballot for the president nited states
right i think that we were talking about
the politics before i think that is a
remarkable fact right there that we have
more shareholders and voters in this
country and what that does the point of
that in is to is to show that people are
have learned an enormous amount about
the stock market particularly about the
values of diversification so free agents
are saying why should i invest if i
would invest all of my financial capital
in a single company why should i invest
all of my human capital in a single
company by working for only one employer
I'm better off like as Deb Ricci was I'm
better off with a portfolio of clients
and assignments and projects than I am
with a single employer I'm diversified
chapter 6 factoids mmm
Americans work 350 hours more per year
than Europeans and 70 hours more per
year than even the Japanese whose
language contains a word karoshi that
means death from overwork mm-hmm well
that's that chapter chapter 6 I tried to
figure out how free agents use their
time and what I did is I asked about 50
people to keep time diaries for a whole
week to tell me everything they did
during every half hour increment of the
day to try to get a sense of how people
navigated a time element of their life
and what I found is it free agents work
about the same number of aggregate hours
as your traditional worker roughly 41
hours but they apportioned their time in
wildly different ways very idiosyncratic
personalized way and III think that the
the issue of time and working hours is
something that this country is trying to
figure out right now because we do work
many more hours than Japanese work and
certainly more than the Europeans work
why do we I think its a mix of reasons I
think for some people it's simply
necessary to get ahead if you have a low
hourly wage you have to work more hours
in order to make a living for your
family but it also think that at the dip
at the other side of the labor market
there's something more intriguing going
on which is that people many people like
to work they work not only to earn a
living they don't necessarily go there
it's no longer the days that everybody
goes to the factory tries to get over
with their job watches the clock all day
tries to get done with their tasks as
quickly as possible so they can go home
but I think people get a lot of
satisfaction out of work and so if you
enjoy something as I enjoy my work as
many free agents enjoy their work you
actually want to work a little bit more
so I think it's a kind of a curious mix
of factors have you thought of politics
yourself well I worked in politics and
that experience was enough for me to
swear off of it for a while for probably
forever yeah you don't think you could
ever run for office oh no why not what
you see up close that the average person
can't uh it's a very very tough life
your private life is incredibly exposed
and I think that that politics pressures
people to say things that they don't
necessarily deeply believe and that
troubled me a lot where's if you write
if you write for yourself you can say
what you think and take and take the
consequences I also think that the
politics is
is that government is not necessarily
the most effective way to get things
done if you work in the executive branch
of the government you come in thinking
okay we can do all kinds of great things
we can change everything and after a few
years you think oh my gosh it's a wonder
that anything is accomplished you work
for Robert rice the former secretary and
Bill Al Gore but you saw the bill
clinton operation up closer what's the
deal between Robert rice and Oakland why
do they not I mean what what you hear a
lot of criticism I rushed what's that
all about I mean what did you see up
close what why was Robert well I was
four I work for Bobby Rush in the in the
early nineteen elite ooh mid-1990s and
their relationship seemed fun I have no
idea what's going on between them they
haven't knew the wonders let me in on
that secret well I just wanted if Robert
rice was you only got out whether or not
he was discouraged by what he had seen
happen when they saw what actually
happens up close with politics maybe I
mean his book is very entertaining book
locked in the cabinet talks about some
of that all right factoid chapter seven
one of the earliest self-organized
clusters of free agents Benjamin
Franklin's junto formed in 1727 created
a subscription library for its members
which in turn became the first public
library in America why is that in this
young well one of the intriguing things
that i found was you have this notion if
people are working for themselves
they're isolated and lonely they're
stuck in their home offices working by
themselves and what I found is that many
many independent workers are fashioning
these very small groups that meet once a
month to talk about business to talk
about life they're sort of one part
board of directors one part group
therapy and i found this absolutely
fascinating these kind of self-organized
tiny groups of people who were meeting
regularly and then i started doing some
more research and i realized as always
there's nothing new Under the Sun that
Benjamin Franklin in 1727 started the
very same kind of group that lasted I
think for 40 years and became as you
said the basis for the first
subscription library and it was a group
of free agents it was small merchants
who would meet once a week above an
alehouse in Philadelphia to talk about
work and Franklin would assign each
member one particular member to write an
essay about a topic of the day and they
would discuss it so this idea that
Americans free agency i think is a very
very quintessentially American fun
Amin on Americans have this incredible
capacity to form small groups whether
it's Bible study groups whether it's
support troops for disease or or whether
it's these new small groups for work all
right in fact I'd chapter 8 and
sociologist mark granovetter 'he's yeah
a classic study of how people find jobs
he discovered that most people found
them through context yeah not through
people who they were very close to that
is yeah well the people found most
people find jobs not through classified
ads or through internet job sites but
through contacts and most of their
context that our most valuable he found
were not the strong ties not your wife
finds your job or your son finds you a
job but weak ties one or two degrees of
separation away because those weak ties
allow you entry entree into worlds that
you don't necessarily know so in his
study he found that most men found there
is study of workers in in Boston most
found their jobs through contacts but
not through close contacts through
somewhat distant contacts what impact
does that have on us oh well free agency
he described in I think very beautiful
terms the the difference between strong
ties that is say your spouse or weak
ties someone who you don't know that
well and he found that what he called
the strength of weak ties that weak ties
allowed you incredible mobility and
entrees to new opportunities and I find
that the free-agent economy depends very
significantly on weak ties someone's
social safety net is there is their
network of contacts and often the most
valuable contacts our contacts that are
one or two degrees of separation away
chapter 10 factoids more than five
percent of workers who earn more than
seventy five thousand dollars per year
now have agents to negotiate their
employment country right well this goes
to the Larry Bird Eugene v Deb's point
that um that more and more workers at
the high end of the talent market want
to be able to negotiate the best
possible deal and they're they're hiring
people to do the negotiation for them
used to be only athletes and actors
would have agents authors as well but
now more and more workers have them how
many agents do you have an
your life too and they are I do why
literary agent race the gallon terrific
literary agent and i also have an agent
who represents me for speaking gigs
David Lavin who's based in Toronto
Canada and out of all this have you
gotten speaking engagements if you what
do you think I'm a writer I'm not a I'm
not a you know a dog and pony show giver
but as a free agent where is this all
headed for you oh I'm just hoping to
continue to write books and have
interesting conversations about
fascinating topics and earn enough money
to support my family what's your wife
doing actually back to work no she's
still at home with her kids but you did
tell us that I think I understood you to
tell a story about how you got medical
insurance right because you had to what
employ her no no although although it's
possible actually there there are a
number of people who are who are free
agents who are taking a twist in the tax
code to employ their spouse and because
of their benevolence as an employer give
their spouse a very full set of health
insurance because today if you're
self-employed your health insurance you
can only deduct sixty percent of your
health insurance premiums but companies
that employ people and pay their health
insurance premiums can deduct one
hundred percent so there's a big
imbalance there as well how many people
are doing that I don't know I you know
it's a I don't know if there's any way
to quantify it factoid in chapter 11
small to mid-size family businesses
account from about sixty percent of all
employment in the world mm-hmm surprise
you a little bit I like because I think
that that we're conditioned to take as
the norm whatever set of social
circumstances we inherit and so all of
us say under the age of 70 or basically
everybody in America today essentially
inherited this world of large
organizations and industrial economy and
we take that as the norm but in fact
it's I think it could go down as an
aberration it used to be the industrial
economy separated work and family it
used to be that you would work at your
home you would work with your family
and that was the norm and the industrial
economy cleave that and I think that
free agents in many ways are repairing
it I work at home they're tens of
millions of people who work at home and
that creates a very different
neighborhood life it creates a very
different family life and I think it's
mostly healthy but it also i think is
much more in tune with how human beings
are wired and that fact though it is
from a very interesting guy at the
University of London and Nigel Nicholson
who is using some of the principles of
evolutionary psychology to understand
business today I must switch the quote
in chapter 12 if you have a job and get
your health insurance through your
employer be thankful it was never
supposed to be this way right again it's
very similar very similar point we take
as the norm in this country the idea
that we get health insurance through our
employers but that is truly a historical
accident in the 1940s there was a wage
freeze to get around the wage freeze
employers said what can we do to lure
people we can't raise salaries let's
give him something let's give him health
insurance so they gave him health
insurance and there are a couple of
policy changes that harden that into the
norm first the IRS determined that
health insurance was not taxable income
even though it was a value that a worker
was getting and also health insurance
was fully deductible for employers so in
a very Swift amount very swiftly getting
health insurance through an employer
became the norm in this country there's
no economic logic there's no more logic
behind it so that's why you can have
this incredibly prosperous country even
in this downturn this is a very
prosperous country but yet 41 million
people without health insurance because
the way our health insurance system is
structured and the way people actually
work and live are increasingly at odds
factoids from chapter 13
african-americans make up eleven percent
of the total workforce but twenty-two
percent of the temps where I'd say to
you it says to me that at one part of
the labor market particularly temps
workers are getting a very very bad deal
there were benefits to an organization
man style of work there was easy access
to decent jobs that pay decent wages and
today in this economy if you don't have
skills and you don't have connections
you're in big trouble whether you're a
free agent or whether you're not and
often the burden of this fall's most
heavily on
low-income workers who are increased who
are who are heavily racial minorities
now as you see me go through all these
factoids in this chapter are you saying
to yourself things like this little plan
of mine work the media is so lazy they
just go to the factors may is that what
you found has happened in your book no I
find that people have I find that people
have very few people who have contacted
me have at least admitted to having read
only the box but I find it useful it's a
useful way to have a conversation there
are many people as I said who read the
book and say oh geez what are you saying
chapter 10 and they have an easy way to
go to that box and find out what's going
on all right I'm so grateful Brian if
you weren't only the fact I'd be
grateful to you chapter 14 factoids when
Franklin Roosevelt established 65 is a
standard us retirement age the average
American life expectancy was 63 today
life expectancy is 76 and rising right
what impacts that going to have to free
agent tree well um I think that our
notions of retirement are going to
change there gonna be more people like
grandma Betty who instead of fully
retiring are going to work as part time
free agents my father who's 70 is an
example of that other people in his
generation are doing that they're
they've left big organizations and now
working as part time free agents I think
there are a whole host of reasons for
that one is that today if you're 70
years old you're really not that old
you've got a lot of good years left in
you and most people I think don't want
to spend 20-30 years playing Canasta and
shuffleboard they want to do something
that is more meaningful they want to do
something that is more engaging and so I
think that's one force and that's the
other thing is that the the demographic
cohorts behind the baby boom are very
small and in a couple of decades we're
going to run out of so-called
working-age people into there's going to
be an incredible demand for a retired
baby boomers run another time can't get
all these factoids in here's another one
chapter fifteen forty percent of college
students are now older than 25 forty
percent of college students are now
older than 25 did that surprise you sure
but it also it also shows that people
are using college in fundamentally
different ways workers are always
looking for ways to sharpen their skills
they can do with their employers but
they can also do it through community
colleges and that's what a lot of people
are doing today chapter 16 factoid at
any given moment there
the work day seventy percent of desks
offices or work stations aren't occupied
sure I mean your desk is unoccupied
right now because you're talking to me
my desk is unoccupied right now because
I'm talking to you I think that free
agency is going to reshape commercial
real estate and the way that offices are
configured what about this one this is
the next chapter nineteen ninety-eight
Arthur Andersen study found that forty
seven percent of entrepreneurs had
financed their businesses with credit
cards yep because there are there are
very great they're very of efficient
capital markets for large companies the
capital markets for small entrepreneurs
are much less efficient but people are
using their credit cards as a way to
bootstrap their businesses so what is
your reaction to the reaction you've
gotten to your book I'm mostly i'm
mostly pleased the reviews have been for
the most part quite good and again the
thematts was most gratifying as an
author is all of the email and phone
calls and comments I get from people who
read the book and said that they liked
it that it really explained their own
lives that it gave them a window onto a
window onto the future back to your time
with Al Gore why'd you leave I was tired
I was burnt out I felt that I didn't
have any control over my life what burns
you out in a job like that working 24
hours a day seven days a week literally
be I am I mean mean but but did working
basically every day of the week as a
writer you're on deadline all the time
and also being tethered to your beeper
again not being fully in control because
at any moment your beeper could go off
and your Saturday afternoon is going to
be spent typing a speech rather than
doing something with your family what do
you know about him that we don't he's an
incredibly funny guy he has an
incredibly sharp and sophisticated sense
of humor why doesn't he let us see it
you have to ask him that I think part of
it is that most politicians are not very
funny and so because in order to be
funny I think you have to say things
that people are thinking but aren't
allowed to say and politics is almost
the opposite of that you'd help you you
do tend to give these banal
blandishments that aren't particularly
interesting but are utterly and
offensive did you ever tell him the deal
lighten up be funny in front of the
public no you know we know we
we actually did a number of kind of
comic routines there and he's incredibly
funny as a very excellent sense of of
comic timing what's your sense will the
man ever be present hard to say I think
he could be I think he'd be a very good
president you think he'll run again I
have no idea would you work for him
again probably back into that probably
not no I don't think so i think partly
you were talking about earlier my
politics have changed a little bit or
they've matured you know i'm i'm still a
registered democrat but by a very thin
thread but i would never become a
registered republican i like to think of
myself now is kind of a bleeding-heart
libertarian and what's the difference
between being a bleeding-heart
libertarian and being a Democrat a
Democrats tend to put too much faith in
large institutions large organizations
rather than in the integrity and freedom
of individuals when did this trip worry
when did this change you know it been
changing over a certain oh you know in a
way you know used to be there's old joke
that a conservative is a liberal who's
been mugged but today I think you know a
libertarian is a liberal who's worked in
the executive branch of the government
it's very poorly run it's um it's not
necessarily the most effective way to
accomplish things and a lot of it is
done for self-preservation rather than
for effectively getting things done but
I still believe that people who are
being left out need need a helping hand
to come up but i think the helping hand
is allowing them to move under their own
steam here's the cover of the book free
agent nation how America's new
independent workers are transforming the
way we live our author has been Daniel H
pink and we thank you very much thank
you